if you look in the top right-hand corner, the little crane you can see,
that is a giant crane.
So that really puts it into perspective.
So, we get phosphorus from mines.
And if I make a comparison with oil,
there’s an oil crisis, we talk about it, we talk about global warming,
yet we never mention the phosphorus crisis.
To come back to the oil problem, oil is something we can replace.
We can use biofuels, or solar power,
or hydropower, but phosphorus is an essential element,
indispensable to life, and we can’t replace it.
What is the current state of the world's phosphorus reserves?
This graph gives you a rough idea of where we are today.
The black line represents predictions for phosphorus reserves.
In 2030, we’ll reach the peak.
By the end of this century, it will all be gone.
The dotted line shows where we are today.
As you can see, they meet in 2030, I’ll be retired by then.
But we are indeed heading for a major crisis,
and I’d like people to become aware of this problem.
Do we have a solution?
What are we to do? We are faced with a paradox.
Less and less phosphorus will be available.
By 2050 there will be 9 billion of us,
and according to the U.N. Food and Agriculture Organization,
we will need to produce twice as much food in 2050 than we do today.
So, we will have less phosphorus, but we'll need to produce more food.
What should we do?
It truly is a paradoxical situation.
Do we have a solution, or an alternative
which will allow us to optimize phosphorus use?
Remember that 80 percent is destined to be lost.
The solution I'm offering today is one that has existed for a very long time,
even before plants existed on Earth,
and it's a microscopic mushroom that is very mysterious,
very simple, and yet also extremely complex.
I've been fascinated by this little mushroom for over 16 years now.
It has led me to further my research
and to use it as a model for my laboratory research.
This mushroom exists in symbiosis with the roots.
By symbiosis, I mean a bidirectional and mutually beneficial association
which is also called mycorrhiza.
This slide illustrates the elements of a mycorrhiza.
You’re looking at the root of wheat,
one of the world’s most important plants.
Normally, a root will find phosphorus all by itself.
It will go in search of phosphorus,
but only within the one millimeter which surrounds it.
Beyond one millimeter, the root is ineffective.
It cannot go further in its search for phosphorus.
Now, imagine this tiny, microscopic mushroom.
It grows much faster,
and is much better designed to seek out phosphorus.
It can go beyond the root’s one-millimeter scope
to seek out phosphorus.
I haven’t invented anything at all;
it's a biotechnology that has existed for 450 million years.
And over time, this mushroom has evolved and adapted to seek out
even the tiniest trace of phosphorus, and to put it to use,
to make it available to the plant.
What you’re seeing here, in the real world, is a carrot root,
and the mushroom with its very fine filaments.
Looking closer, we can see that this mushroom
is very gentle in its penetration.
It will proliferate between the root's cells,
eventually penetrating a cell
and starting to form a typical arbuscular structure,
which will considerably increase the exchange interface
between the plant and the mushroom.
And it is through this structure that mutual exchanges will occur.
It’s a win-win trade:
I give you phosphorus, and you feed me.
True symbiosis.
Now let's add a mycorrhiza plant
into the diagram I used earlier.
And instead of using a 100 percent dose, I’m going to reduce it to 25 percent.
You’ll see that of this 25 percent, most will benefit the plant,
more than 90 percent.
A very small amount of phosphorus will remain in the soil.
That's completely natural.
What's more is that in certain cases, we don't even need to add phosphorus.
If you recall the graphs I showed you earlier,
85 percent of phosphorus is lost in the soil,
and the plants are unable to access it.
Even though it is present in the soil, it is in insoluble form.
The plant is only able to seek out soluble forms.
The mushroom is capable of dissolving this insoluble form
and making it available for the plant to use.
To further support my argument, here is a picture that speaks for itself.
These are trials in a field of sorghum.
On the left side, you see the yield produced using conventional agriculture,
with a 100 percent phosphorus dose.
On the other side, the dose was reduced to 50 percent,
and just look at the yield.
With only a half-dose, we achieved a better yield.
This is to show you that this method works.
And in some cases, in Cuba, Mexico and India,
the dose can be reduced to 25 percent, and in several other cases,
there's no need to add any phosphorus at all,
because the mushrooms are so well adapted
to finding phosphorus and drawing it from the soil.
This is an example of soy production in Canada.
Mycorrhiza was used in one field but not in the other.
And here, where blue indicates a better yield, and yellow a weaker yield.
The black rectangle is the plot
from which the mycorrhiza was added.
In other words, as I already said, I have invented nothing.
Mycorrhiza has existed for 450 million years,
and it has even helped modern-day plant species to diversify.
So, this it isn't something that is still undergoing lab tests.
Mycorrhiza exists, it works,
it's produced at an industrial scale and commercialized worldwide.
The problem is that people are not aware of it.
People like food producers and farmers are still not aware of this problem.
We have a technology that works,
and one that, if used correctly, will alleviate some of the pressure
we are putting on the world's phosphorus reserves.
In conclusion, I am a scientist and a dreamer.
I'm passionate about this topic.
So if you were to ask me what my retirement dream is,
which will be at the moment we reach that phosphorus peak,
it would be that we use one label, "Made with mycorrhiza,"
and that my children and grandchildren
buy products bearing that label too.
Thank you for your attention.
(Applause)